Schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Ujak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesigespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich Herr Doktor.
Danke. Bitte fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, okay?
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich bin Efer Neuhaus.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja. E-V-A-E-F-N-I-U-H-A-U-S. Neuhaus.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, wie alt sind Sie?
42 Jahre alt, Herr Doktor.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
18 April 1983.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,65 Meter.
Und wie schwer sind Sie zuzeit?
70 Kilogramm, Doktor.
Okay. Danke für die Informationen.
Frau Neuhaus, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Übungen haben Sie zuzeit?
Seit gestern habe ich sehr starke Rücken Schmerzen.
Wo genau sind diese Schmerzen? Ich meine im Mittel oder?
Ja, im Mittel, Doktor.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind sie eher drückend, stechend, brennend?
Ja, ich habe sofort eine steckende Schmerzen in den unteren Rücken, Doktor.
Okay. Ich glaube, die Schmerzen sind plötzlich aufgetreten, richtig?
Ja, richtig. Sie haben Recht.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, schreien diese Schmerzen irgendwo aus?
Ja, die Schmerzen strahlen ins rechte Bein und bis zu den rechten Szenen aus, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, wie stark sieht sich diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala,
wobei eins sehr leichten und zehn sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Ich würde die Schmerzen mit 10 von 10 der Schmerzskala bewerten, Doktor.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, das ist eine sehr starke Schmerzen.
Ja.
Also ich möchte Ihnen einen Schmerzmittel geben, aber ich möchte zuerst wissen, ob Sie eine Allergie gegen Medikamente haben.
Ich reagiere allergisch auf keine Medikamente, Doktor.
Okay. Das freut mich. Schwester Müller, bitte geben Sie der Patientin Schmerzmittel.
Frau Neuhaus, wie fühlen Sie sich? Besser?
Ja, ich fühle mich jetzt besser, Doktor. Danke schön.
Okay. Das freut mich. Frau Neuhaus, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen ein Medikament eingenommen?
Ich habe noch keine Schmerzmittel eingenommen, Herr Doktor, und möchte derzeit auch keine.
Okay. Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein. Ich hatte früher keine anderen Beschwerden. Nein. Ich hatte.
Okay. Sind Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich bin deswegen nicht an dem Arzt gewesen, Doktor.
Okay. Alles klar. Frau Neuhaus, leiden Sie unter Taubheitsgefühl oder Kriben am Bein, am Fuß? Ich meine.
Ja, Doktor. Sie haben recht. Zusätzlich habe ich ein Taubheitsgefühl und Kriben im rechten Bein bemerkt, Doktor. Ja.
Okay. Und haben Sie Bewegungseinschränkungen bemerkt?
Nein. Ich habe nicht bemerkt. Nein. Aber wissen Sie Doktor, die Schmerzen haben, ich habe gesagt, plötzlich angefangen, als ich gestern in den Garten einen schweren Stein getragen habe, Doktor.
Ja, ich habe sofort einen steckenen Schmerz in meinem Rücken gespürt. Ja. Und musste ich mich gleich hinlegen.
Und beim Aufrichten und Drehen werden die Schmerzen schlimmer. Aber im Liegen geht es mir ein bisschen besser.
Verstehen Sie Doktor? Ja, Frau Neuhaus. Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, während dieser Situation hatten Sie eine unwillkürliche Wassergelassene oder Stüllabgang?
Nein. Nein Doktor. Das freut mich. Okay. Alles klar.
Frau Neuhaus, ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie erbrechen?
Ich habe keine Übel oder Erbrechen Doktor. Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Deswegen diese Schmerzen habe ich Appetitlosigkeit. Ja.
Okay. Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit wirklich Ab- oder Suge genommen?
Nein. Ich denke, ich bin immer gleich gewischt.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber, Schüterfrost oder Nachschweiß?
Schüterfrost, Nachschweiß. Ich habe nicht bemäht Doktor.
Okay. Ist alles in Ordnung beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Ich habe keine Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang.
Super. Frau Neuhaus, leiden Sie unter Husten oder Luftnot?
Nein. Ich habe keine dieser Probleme.
Okay. Schlafen Sie gut?
Seit gestern kann ich wegen der Schmerzen schlecht schlafen Doktor. Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich denke, beide.
Okay. Sind Sie schon vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Corona-Infektionen geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig gegen die Corona-Infektionen geimpft.
Alles klar. Frau Neuhaus, leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Ja, ich habe...
Wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, ich habe Typ 1 Zuckerkrankheit seit meiner Jugend.
Und spritzen Sie dagegen Insulin?
Ja, sie haben recht. Ich benutze dagegen Insulinpumpe. Ja.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Außerdem habe ich eine hohe Blutwerte, Hyperlipidemie.
Frau Neuhaus, ich habe die Akustik nicht richtig verstanden.
Leiden Sie an erhöhte Blutwertwerte oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, ich habe auch eine hohe Fettige Blutwerte, Hyperlipidemie.
Ja, und leiden Sie...
Ja, Hyperlipidemie, nicht Bluthochdruck, Doktor.
Okay, alles klar. Seit wann leiden Sie?
Seit 5 Jahren, Doktor.
Okay. Nehmen Sie dagegen ein Medikament ein?
Ja, ich nehme dagegen 40 mg Zortis ein.
Wie oft nehmen Sie ein?
Morgens einmal täglich.
Okay. Sonst noch etwas?
Ja, ständig nehme ich Pantoprosol und zwei weitere Medikamente bei Bedarf.
Aber deren Name weiß ich nicht, Doktor. Leider nicht.
Wogegen nehmen Sie diese Medikamente ein?
Manchmal habe ich Zortbrennen und Magenschmerzen.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Zortbrennen und Magenschmerzen?
Es ist sehr lange, ungefähr 10 oder 12 Jahre.
Okay. Und Sie nehmen regelmäßig Pantoprosol ein?
Ja.
Und auch zwei weitere Medikamente?
Bei Bedarf.
Sie kennen den Namen nicht?
Aber ich weiß gerade nicht, wie es heißt.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Medikamentliste dabei?
Jetzt nicht, aber in meiner Hausart.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, wer ist Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Meine Hausärztin heißt Frau Fischer.
Okay. Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen. Ich werde Ihre Frauin erst kontaktieren.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Okay. Sehr gerne. Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Pantoprosol ...
... und weitere zwei Medikamente.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung von Pantoprosol?
Ja. Ich habe vergessen, Doktor. Nein.
Alles klar. Kein Problem.
Sonst noch etwas? Irgendwelche anderen Erkrankungen?
Das war es.
Okay. Frau Neuhaus, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf außer genannten Medikamenten ...
... irgendwelche anderen Medikamente ein?
Ja. Nein, Doktor. Ich habe keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Okay. Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja. Ich wurde noch nie operiert, Doktor.
Noch nie operiert.
Wie bitte?
Ich wurde noch nie operiert.
Super. Okay. Ihr habt jetzt gehört.
Also manchmal kann ich Sie nicht hören. Okay.
Okay.
Aber ich hatte zwei Unfalle in der Werkangabe.
Eine Prallung des Oberschenkelknochen und eine Fersen bei Infraktur.
Aber beide wurden konservativ behandelt, Doktor.
Okay. Wann waren diese Unfälle?
Eine war vor drei Jahren, die andere war sechs Jahren.
Also darf ich fragen, wann war die Prallung?
Unter den Oberschenkelknochen, habe ich gesagt.
Okay. Wann war das?
Vor drei Jahren.
Okay. Und Fersen bei ...
Fersen bei Infraktur vor sechs Jahren.
Okay. Alles klar.
Frau Neujahrs, sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergen bekannt?
Ich habe eine Hühnweise Allergie, Doktor.
Eine Eierweise Allergie.
Okay. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Das ist mit Durchfall und Atemnot ausgedrückt.
Okay. Frau Neujahrs, rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche seit meinem 20. Lebensjahr, Doktor.
Und wie viel rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche halb Schachtel Zigaretten täglich.
Okay. Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gelegentlich ein Glas Wein, wenn ich Besuch habe oder eine Ferne.
Alles klar. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich. Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Drogen? Drogen habe ich nicht konsumiert, Doktor. Nein.
Okay. Das freut mich.
Frau Neujahrs, leiden Ihre Eltern an chronischen Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Wie zum Beispiel Schlaganfall, Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja. Mein Vater hat eine Milzentfernung operiert.
Ihre Mutter?
Meine Mutter hat vor etwa drei oder vier Jahren einen Oberschenkelbruch.
Okay. Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie sind gesund.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand, Frau Neujahrs?
Ich habe einen Lebensgefährte, Doktor.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Mit wem wohnen Sie? Mit Ihren Karten?
Mit meinem Lebensgefährte.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich arbeite als Betriebsführer.
Betriebs?
Betriebsführer.
Betriebsleiter in einer Firma.
Okay. Sind Sie zufrieden bei der Arbeit?
Ich bin zufrieden, aber seitdem habe ich sehr viel Stress durch die Arbeit.
Viele Personal, viele Kollegen.
Ich bin Leiter. Es gibt viele Probleme. Verstehen Sie?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Wenn Sie möchten, können wir Sie dabei unterstützen, Frau Neujahrs.
Das ist ein gutes Programm hier im Krankenhaus.
Ich meine, wie eine Psychotherapie, wenn Sie möchten.
Ja, Doktor, es wäre Ihnen denkbar, wenn Sie mir helfen können.
Ja, gerne. Wir können darüber sprechen, aber nach dem Aufnahmegespräch.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Neujahrs, das waren meine Fragen. Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, Doktor, was habe ich?
Ich muss arbeiten oder ich habe starke Schmerzen, Krippen. Ja, ich habe viele Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut, Frau Neujahrs. Aber machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorgen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, hierher zu kommen.
Und ich vermute, dass Sie einen Bandschadenvorfall haben.
Deswegen werde ich Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Und dann werde ich Ihnen Blut abnehmen und ein paar Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse da sind, werde ich Ihnen die weiteren Informationen mitteilen.
Bei mir wird eine Operation durchgeführt, Doktor. Ich habe keine Angst.
Frau Neujahrs, leider kann es passieren, dass Sie operiert werden müssen.
Aber es ist zu früh, um über die Therapiemöglichkeiten zu sprechen.
Wie gesagt, muss ich zuerst ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Danach können wir eine 100% sichere Diagnose und über Therapiemöglichkeiten widersprechen.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen, Doktor?
Ja.
Bleibe ich im Krankenhaus oder kann ich gehen in mein Haus?
Frau Neujahrs, in ein paar Stunden müssen Sie sicherlich bei uns bleiben, damit wir die Diagnose bestätigen können.
Aber wenn wir etwas Auffälliges finden, kann es auch passieren, dass Sie ein paar Tage im Krankenhaus bleiben sollen.
Ok, Doktor. Ich warte auf Sie. Danke schön.
Frau Neujahrs, ich möchte noch eine Frage stellen. Wie sind Sie mit dem Rettungsdienst gekommen?
Selbst.
Ok, alles klar. Danke.
Bitte.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartezimmer. Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Danke schön, Doktor.
Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über Sie berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Eva Neujahrs ist 42 Jahre alt, 1,65 Meter groß und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Neujahrs stellte sich heute bei uns notfallmäßig wegen seit gestern bestehender Lumbargie bei einer Gartenarbeit nach einem Hebe Trauma vor.
Der Patient ist zufolge seien die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien stechend und würden in das rechte Bein und in den rechten Sehen ausschalten.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzkala von 10 von 10 bewahrt und die Patienten haben gegen diese Schmerzen keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Sie berichtete über Parasthesie und Hypesthesie. Die Fragen nach Bewegungseinschränkungen und Urininkontinenz und Stullinkontinenz wurden verneint.
Die Schmerzen hatten sich beim Hinlegen verbessern und beim Drehen verschleppen.
Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die folgenden bekannt. Schmerzbedingte Inapetenz und Schmerzbedingte Insomnie in Form von Einschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten und dreimal Covid-19-Infektionen geimpft.
Anvor Erkrankungen nannte sie seit Jugend bestehenden Diabetes mellitus Typ 1 und seit fünf Jahren bestehende Hyperlipidemie und seit zwölf Jahren bestehende Pirosis und Magenschmerzen.
Die Patienten benutzen eine Insulinpumpe gegen Diabetes mellitus Typ 1 und sie nehmen Sortis 40 mg morgens gegen Hyperlipidemie ein.
Außerdem nehmen die Patienten Pantoprazole und noch andere zwei Medikamente ein.
Aber die Namen der Medikamente und die Dosierung der Medikamente sollte geklärt werden.
Vor drei Jahren erlitten sie an einer Rippenprellung eine Oberschenkelfemurprellung, die konservativ behandelt worden sei.
Vor sechs Jahren haben sie an einer Kalkenosefraktur gezogen.
Sie sei bisher noch nie operiert worden.
Sie habe Allergie gegen Hühnereiweiß, die sich durch Diarrhohe und Dyspne äußert.
Sie sei Raucherin und sie rauche eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten täglich seit 20 Jahren.
Sie trinken gelegentlich Alkohol.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass der Vater eine Pschyptenektomie hatte.
Die Mutter hatte an einer Femurfraktur vor vier Jahren erlitten.
Sie hatte eine gesunde Schwester.
Sie sei ledig.
Sie habe kein Kind und wohne mit ihrem Partner zusammen.
Sie sei eine Betriebsleiterin in einer Firma und habe zu viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Diskusprolaps im Lendenbereich aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter Lumbaralgie.
Sie leidet unter eine Plötzlich aufgetretene Lumbaralgie nach dem Hebertrauma und Hypostasie und Parasthesie am Bein und am Fuß.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine Diskusprolaps LWS.
Als Differenzdiagnose kommen Muskelspannungen, Wirbelsäure, Fraktur und diabetesche Neuropathie in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich bei der Patientin zunächst die Vitaparabete überwachen und eine körperliche und neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob eine Skoliose, Lordose oder Muskelspannungen vorhanden sind.
Ich würde auch die Druckschmerzen bei der Wirbelsäule kontrollieren.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob Störungen der Motorik, Sensorik und andere Veränderungen vorliegen.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Dabei würde ich Blutbild, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, CAP, BSG, Blutgruppe bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine Röntgenuntersuchung durchführen, um mögliche Frakturen zu beurteilen.
Normalerweise würde ich eine MRT überprüfen, um die möglichen Pathologien zu überprüfen.
Bei dieser Patientin ist eine MRT quanta-indiziert wegen Insulinpumpe.
Deswegen würde ich eine CT durchführen, um die möglichen Pathologien genau zu beurteilen.
Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde einen Venosynzugang legen und Analgetikum und Muskelrelaxanten verabreichen.
Danach würde ich ein orthopäisches Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patientin zu optimieren.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vollgeheizweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung vollfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben gesagt, dass die Diagnose nicht finanziell ausführt. Wie können Sie diese Diagnose ausführen?
Wir können bei dieser Patientin eine Elektroneuro-Myografie durchführen, um die Diabetische Neuropathie auszuschließen.
Können Sie uns die Elektroneuro-Myografie aufklären?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich einige Details zu diesem Thema habe. Aber ich werde es nach der Erpüffung recherchieren.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben auch gesagt, dass die Diagnose nicht finanziell ausführt. Wie können Sie diese Diagnose ausführen?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung bei der Paltation können wir die Muskelspannungen feststellen.
Gegen diese Beschwerden können wir eine Wärmetherapie, Physiotherapie oder eine Krankengymnastik empfehlen.
Aber wenn alles in Ordnung ist, dann ist es bei der Nervensysteme.
Können Sie uns die CT aufklären?
Ich werde Sie gerne über CT aufklären.
Computer-Tomographie gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumoren oder andere Veränderungen genau zu erkennen.
Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe Strahlenbelastung und völlig schmerzfrei.
Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten ruhig in einer CT-Röhre liegen.
Wenn der Patient eine Glatzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten ein Beruhigungsmittel geben.
Manchmal müssen wir ein Kontrastmittel geben, um die Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Es gibt einige Kontraindikationen, wie z.B. Schwangerschaft und Kontrastmittelallergie.
Es gibt keine Komplikationen bei dieser Untersuchung.
Nach der Untersuchung gibt es keine Einschränkungen und der Patient kann den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
Für diese Untersuchung benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung.
Wann entscheiden Sie in diesem Fall eine Operation?
Es gibt neurologische Befunde bei diesem Patienten, der unter Hypesthesie und Parastese leidet.
Das ist ein Risikofaktor bei diesem Patienten.
Deswegen würde ich eine Operation empfehlen.
Normalerweise können wir bei diesem Patienten eine Wärmetherapie, Schmerzmitteiltherapie, muskelentspannende Therapie und Krankengymnastik empfehlen.
Aber wenn diese symptomatische Therapie keine Antworten bringt, dann können wir eine Operation empfehlen.
Oder wenn es neurologische Befunde wie Hypesthesie, Parastese oder Hemiparesie gibt, dann können wir direkt eine Operation empfehlen.
Was meinen Sie? Muskelschwäche?
Ich meine Muskelschwäche und manchmal Inkontinenz, wie zum Beispiel Urininkontinenz oder Stuhlinkontinenz.
Denken Sie in diesem Fall TFT?
Also ich habe keine Frage über TFT gestellt.
Die Patienten leiden unter keine Beinschwellungen, keine Rötung am Bein.
Es gibt nur Hypesthesie und Parastese.
Aber ich würde auch diese Fragen stellen, um eine TFT auszuschließen.
Sie haben recht.
Hat Sie offene Runde im Bein?
Leider habe ich diese Frage auch nicht gestellt.
Aber nach dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch werde ich diese Fragen stellen.
Wie können Sie TFT in diesem Fall ausschließen?
Wir können eine Doppler-Sonographie durchführen, um eine Thrombose auszuschließen.
Und wir können auch eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Und wir können Ödeme, Erytheme und Überwärmung feststellen.
Welche Laborwerte möchten Sie?
Als Laborwerte würde ich eine Dedimere bestimmen lassen.
Das ist sehr wichtig bei einer TFT.
Denken Sie in diesem Fall auch P auf HK?
Die Patientin leidet unter keine Beinschmerzen.
Sie leidet unter nur Hypesthesie und Parastese.
Aber wir sollen einige Fragen über dieses Thema stellen.
Wie zum Beispiel haben Sie Schmerzen beim Laufen?
Oder brauchen Sie eine Pause beim Laufen?
Aber aufgrund der aktuellen Beschwerden denke ich keine P auf HK.
Wie können Sie P auf HK ausschließen?
Bei einer körperlichen Untersuchung?
Wir sollen auf jeden Fall die peripheren Pulsen abtasten.
Wie zum Beispiel Arterie dorsalis pedis und Arterie tibialis posterior.
Das ist sehr wichtig bei einer P auf HK.
Welchen Index kontrollieren Sie?
Ich habe den Namen schon vergessen, aber wir sollen die Blutdruck zwischen Armen und Beinen vergleichen.
Ein Braschendegs?
Ja, wir haben recht.
Ist es möglich in diesem Fall auch Stimmgabel-Tests?
Aber geht es uns falsch?
Ich denke nicht so.
Die Patientin leidet unter keine Cephalgie oder Vertigo oder Höchstschwierigkeit.
Oder eine Zentralnervös-Systemprobleme.
Also ich würde keine Test durchführen.
Können Sie Stimmgabel-Tests bei Druckgefühl?
Nein, leider nicht.
Bei einer neuropäischen Neuropathie ausschließen können wir auch Stimmgabel-Tests bei Fuß-Mantreiben.
Danke für diese neue Information, Herr Oberarzt.
Okay, Herr Kollegen, bitte gehen Sie in unseren Infodisc und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifikat.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg für Ihren Arbeitszweck.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarzt. Sie sind sehr nett. Das war ein schönes, angenehmes Sprech bei mir. Vielen Dank.